I've seen no evidence yet how that can
happen
the key thing I'm aware of is even as we
speak
I know there are Londoners who are
losing their lives as a consequence of
this awful virus and what's important is
we don't inadvertently allow the virus
to spread fast again which could lead to
a second spike which could overwhelm the
NHS we had London and across the country
have put in a monumental effort so far
following the instructions to save lives
and protect the NHS why I think would be
unwise for us to inadvertently rush back
to lift the lockdown which could lead to
a further spread I'm quite clear my
interpretation from what the prime
minister said last night
we discussed this during the cobra
meeting is the lockdown is still there
for at least three weeks the social
business it measures us that in place
well the prime minister and Dominic Rob
are setting up is a road map about what
could happen in the future but at each
stage we're going to review the evidence
see what's happening what we don't want
to do is have to go into reverse care
that's why it's really important we are
cautious I understand the reason why
everyone needs hope what's even more
important is to save lives he said he
wants construction workers and those in
the manufacturing industry to get back
to work as soon as it's safely possible
not to use public transport for now what
are you going to do about public
transport in London which of course is
the most used in the whole of the
country to try to make people safe when
they are travelling on it outside London
may not know this but in London on a
daily basis before the virus with more
than 4 million tube journeys and more
than 6 million bus journeys at the
moment were running roughly 5% of shoot
capacity about 10% of buses which is to
adhere to social distancing we can't
increase that much more and not breach
the rules so we've seen a number of
things firstly the government today will
be shown guidance saying anybody who is
in a confined space and can't keep their
social distance Brooks
using public transport should wear
non-medical facial coverings to stop
themselves inadvertently passing on the
virus and so from today our transport
staff will be wearing the basic face
masters taught themselves passing on the
virus
but the advice is quite clear please
only use public transport if you really
really have to and if you do avoid the
rush hour and a message to any employers
who are asking their staff to return to
work is please stagger your start times
stagger your shifts so we can make sure
that we don't have public transport
congested a rush hour which could lead
to the virus but in faster than it
currently is okay from around the world
and experts in America Canada Germany
South Korea Taiwan elsewhere ease the
non-medical facial covering stops the
virus spreading you could be
asymptomatic or pre-symptomatic and you
may pass it away it doesn't stop you
catching it but it stops passing on but
the advice isn't to wear gloves okay and
as far as London schools are concerned
what you want to see happen that junuh
first as the private has said reception
year one and year six the key thing game
K is not to have too many children using
public transport during rush hour so
we're asking the government to work with
the schools to see if it's possible to
stagger the start times at the end times
of schools I mean on a normal day before
this virus we have roughly speaking 1.5
million children using our buses and
roughly speaking to a thousand children
using our tubes so I'm welcome only some
classes were turning on Judith first the
key thing is to make sure that
inadvertently push children on too busy
tubes and busy buses during rush hour
okay 40 seconds to offer but I just want
to ask you about busy airports or work
wants busy airports here in London
around the m25 quarantine aim for 14
days good idea yes or no yes good idea
including Eurostar as well also
test trace and isolate for some reason
the government abandoned this in the
second week of March it's crucial all
the successful countries have been doing
it we've got to do it as well